hello folks time for another movie
retrospective going back to the 80s
going back to sort of a horror comedy
that I feel like doesn't get quite the
attention as some of the other horror
comedies from the 80s likes when the
more iconic ones this is the burbs from
1989 I have never seen it you had never
seen it you know she showed it to me it
was the first time I've seen it yeah I
feel like this is another one this movie
even though it came out much later than
say the man with two brains which we
also did a retrospective on I feel like
it's kind of occupies the same like
cultural space it's like it's a movie
that had a lot of big stars in it had a
really big director like a well-known
director and it's like really funny has
aged really well but for some reason it
doesn't seem to like come up in
conversation as much as you know some of
the other like better known ones you
know what I mean
what I noticed is ahead it had that very
stereotypical 1980s and 90s era
konna corporate middle america yeah five
to it yeah all the houses and the cars
and kind of like the corporate culture
with consumerism but as everybody was
kind of manifesting it in different ways
some of the some of the people were
misfits you know some of the fans are
misfits and some of them were more you
know I guess you say mainstream yeah
yeah it reminded me of kind of grown up
well I feel like and like I said this
was another movie that I saw probably a
million times like in the late 80s and
early 90s I might have seen in the
theater I can't really remember but I
for sure saw it on you know cable like
for years and years afterward I think I
even taped it on VHS and for real me and
my just like just like man with two
brains this movie is so [ __ ] quotable
but if you like say quotes from it
nobody knows what the hell you're
talking about much like I mentioned on
man with two brains I said if I say to
somebody you cooked her nines they don't
know what I'm talking about
same thing here it's like me and my
brother would be in [ __ ] like
Michaels or Joann Fabric because their
fabrics or whatever and you'd see like a
like a picture frame like with a stock
photo of a person we'd go came with the
frame and like no one would
so this is another one of those movies
that I saw a million times as a kid and
shudder added it just recently and I was
so excited and I wanted to see see it
again and see if I liked it as much as I
did back then and happily it really does
hold up now this is a very bold
statement that I'm gonna make perhaps or
a hot take or whatever you want to call
it this was directed by Joe Dante
obviously probably most famous for
gremlins but he also made the howling
inner space he made like tons and tons
of other movies of this type in the 80s
I'm going to say I like the burbs better
than gremlins a little bit better
there are different kind of movies they
are very different kind of because and I
mean gremlins shudder also added
gremlins 1 & 2 so I watched all three of
these like within a few days of each
other because I hadn't seen gremlins
since I was a kid so I wanted to see I
loved gremlins but I do feel like it's
like zanier and I feel like the UM the
scenes like with you know when they turn
into the gremlins and they kind of go
wreaking havoc around the town and
everything like I feel like those parts
like go on a little bit too long like
with other props like look ones and
Dragon ones you blowing this thing up
and once you know I remember seeing that
in its day and people were enjoying
those extended see yeah it's back in
those days you weren't really used to
that level of special-effects right
because those nights were amazing they
were obviously puppets yeah they're
really good puppets yeah and I remember
being impressed thinking man those
things look pretty real yeah look at it
now they don't look real at all but
they're still awesome puppet they're not
as pup they're good puppets but they
don't look real and that's a it's a
pretty damn saini movie out it's a near
than I remember yeah how about two
gremlin movies I'm gonna say my
grandma's two is better than gremlins
one and in a way it seems like this
story had a little bit of a bigger scope
although grandmas one was good too well
I I like gremlins one better than just
because I like the the small-town feel
of it more than because the second one
was kind of in the big city and gremlins
2 is basically a retake on die hard it
was yeah that was yeah but the thing
about the burbs is that you know the guy
that wrote it
Joe Don's he's in a right
but the guy that wrote it said that he
got the idea he's like I wanted to take
this idea of like this perfect childhood
like like he had had like an Ozzie and
Harriet type of childhood where
everybody knew their neighbors and stuff
like that he said but you know even when
you grow up in an environment like that
like in middle middle America or
whatever he's like every now and then
you'd hear about like some neighbor of
yours that like flipped out and like
shot his whole family and stuff like
that so he really wanted to do a comedy
kind of exploring you know kind of the
dark side of suburbia but make it super
super funny well it's understandable I
mean right if you look at these movies
today especially this one you it could
dovetail right in with that dead mall
culture that you find online yeah people
that like to look at you know Dan Bell
dead mall videos this is like son this
movie is from that era
yeah malls were just yeah 89 woman you
know and mainstream middle America
especially like white Middle America
there was this lifestyle we were kind of
our parents were being sold really is
more than our parents know so much our
generation like a cynical best yeah but
more kind of like of it like a new and
improved more corporate friendlier
version of the 1950's culture yeah and
we we thought was all futuristic and
that it thinks we're gonna build upon
that realized that [ __ ] was gonna fall
apart yeah you know and people got
credit cards and jobs and they paid
credit cards rotating credit and they
just thought it would just go on forever
you know endless consumption exponential
growth and you know I'll be a
millionaire in a couple years it's not
wait for you dude your plant shut down
your shot your job got exported you know
it's just it was a different time
but like I said you watching these
things just kind of brings me back to
the yeah and everyone kind of had or our
parents when you when you lived in those
suburban environments it kind of had a
veneer of acceptability and it was
almost kind of like a uniform in a
certain way but some people were
perpetrating they were fronting yeah be
that that's not who they really were
yeah there's a temporary status you know
so yeah it'd kill each other or they you
know yeah get involved with drugs or he
dumped his wife for a girl who's 20
years younger
just all kinds of [ __ ] what I mean I
think probably that's why I liked this
movie so much just because you know one
like I said we're Gen X we tend to be
like very cynical of everything that's
told to us and also I didn't grow up in
a middle-class you know which I grew up
in a [ __ ] trailer park you know very
poor and so it was like it was something
that it just seemed like [ __ ] to me
because I knew like my family didn't
have all those things and you know it to
me it just seemed very fake so I think I
liked this movie so much just because
it's almost like lampooning that type of
thing like in a gentle sort of way it's
not mean-spirited really but yeah so and
I should note too that the neighborhood
where this was shot is not an actual
neighborhood it was on a universal back
lot and it's the same neighborhood that
they filmed Leave It to Beaver same
neighborhood where they filmed dragnet
that from the 80s the one which also had
Tom Hanks in it which this does as well
had the monsters house that they kind of
you know messed with the front of it so
you couldn't filmed it so you can really
see and so it wouldn't be recognized but
it's a very it's it's in like tons of
movies and TV shows like just redressed
in various ways but that's why I think
Joe Dante didn't really want to shoot it
just in one location at first but when
they said you know yeah this is kind of
like because he said it's almost kind of
like it could work as a stage play which
I'm like yeah it actually kind of could
no no it wasn't but he said it could
work as one just because it was whole
set and it's just in this one
neighborhood like on a cul-de-sac really
not even a whole neighborhood but like I
said if the neighborhood and the houses
look familiar it's because it's on a
universal back lot and has been used in
millions millions of things so he liked
playing with that you know that you got
this feeling of like oh it's the Leave
It to Beaver neighborhood because it was
so so the premise of the story Tom Hanks
is Ray Peterson and at this stage I
think now he's probably I mean nowadays
he's probably known more for his like
dramatic roles and stuff like that but
in the 80s he was like the go-to guy for
being your everyman for a comedy I mean
he grew up he came up in comedy he was
in pretty much exclusively comedies I
think until the late 80s or early 90s if
I recall correctly so
they got him to be you know the lead in
this and I think he was really perfectly
cast because he's so good at one being
relatable and likeable but also he's
funny without it being like without
really trying to be you know what I mean
like he's not cracking jokes it's just
he was a goofy guy yeah that's it's a
very natural like organic yeah later on
ninis letter on the end up being
considered like a serious actor like
doing dramatic roles but yes sir Massa
like guy he's just this geek in this
well he started on a bosom buddies like
up that say yeah I didn't see that
though I was in a movie there's a movie
about Dungeons and Dragons I think mazes
and monsters maze demas that was a TV
movie yeah about the evils and damn it
sucked it really was too well it's bad
in a way that's like kind of
entertaining like while you're cringing
too but that was yes yeah he didn't
really stand out he still stood out only
in retrospect looking back on any
Constanza yeah when he was first
appeared in these movies remember would
I didn't know if he was gonna do that
dude yeah which is money yeah it's funny
they became like super super super fans
I really didn't notice that guy till
like when we played the mentally
challenged guy where it's got thorns
yeah forest yeah yeah but like I said I
think I think that his like natural
humor that he brings the role like I
said he doesn't crack jokes he's not
like wisecracking or anything like that
um that role in this movie actually goes
to Rick duChemin who is his I think
started out and stand up if I remember
correctly but he used to like is like
goofy chunky neighbor that's like you
know what kind of wisecracking all the
time but so so whatever they don't
really specify look what Tom Hanks his
job is in this movie but he is taking a
vacation or as they would call it a
staycation he's just gonna stay home and
lounge around the house and not work and
not do anything all week now his wife is
played by a Carrie Fisher and she is
obviously not super jazzed about having
him hanging around the house but you
know he's like insistent he's just gonna
hang around and do nothing just gonna
sit around in his robe or whatever now
as it happens you know there's kind of
like all these
but they're all like kind of eccentric
and they all live on this street but
they've noticed that this new family has
moved into one of the houses the klopek
s-- and no one has ever really seen them
but they don't mow their lawn they don't
like clean up everything you know the
house is like kind of crappy looking and
they've noticed that sometimes at night
there's this weird glow like coming out
of the basement and there's like all
this really weird noise and that like a
big machine is running or something like
that so they all get like super super
curious about what the [ __ ] is going on
over there
and so while ray played by Tom Hanks is
on vacation him and his neighbor who's
played by Rick duChemin and his other
neighbor who's played by Bruce Dern
who's like a army lieutenant or
something like that he's a Vietnam
veteran
yeah and he's kind of like a little
crazy um they all decide that they're
gonna kind of stake out the neighbor's
house and see what the [ __ ] deal is
with these people right so that's kind
of the set up of the whole movie and I
probably I'm probably gonna spoil it so
you know like I said it came out in 1989
so just chill out but so the whole
premise of the movie like I said so
these three guys you know are like
sneaking around the neighborhood and
trying to figure out so they're like
spying on the neighbors they see them
doing like kind of weird things like the
one guy Hans who's actually played by
the same guy that played the [ __ ] the
tall redheaded kid that was in children
of the corn that played Malachi okay you
know who I mean
yeah he plays this with like a scruffy
kind of beard and they see him one night
like backing the car out of the driveway
and then putting this big garbage bag
that looks like a body and he's putting
in the garbage can and then he like
starts whacking at it with a hoe like
he's trying to kill it or something like
that so they're like that's got to be a
body you guys we're gonna check out you
know so then like the next day like the
[ __ ] garbage truck comes and they're
like there's stops a band they have to
like digging through the garbage that'll
leave in [ __ ] garbage all over the
road and [ __ ] like that and they don't
find anything and then they they also
see them kind of like digging in the
backyard like out in the dark in the
rain and they're like oh they're burying
bodies and so it just kind of like keeps
escalating and they just are
like you know these three guys obviously
have nothing better to do and like their
wives are just sitting there going you
guys are stupid it's like there's
nothing going on over there you're just
harassing these poor people for no
reason and but they're like no they just
insist that there's something going on
over there and then one of their
neighbors this old guy named Walter he
has like this poodle or Bichon free
source of light and it keeps like
pooping in other people's yards and so
there's kind of that whole thing going
on and they notice that his dog is
running around loose and then we when
they go over to his house he's like not
there and then one of them ray I think
finds a like a bone in his backyard and
is clearly a human bone so at this point
they're like okay well all bets are off
so they wait until the [ __ ] klopek
have gone out for the day and then they
start like you know they cut their alarm
system and they like break into their
house and [ __ ] like that they're like we
are not leaving until we find a dead
body we're gonna prove that this is
what's going on and stuff like that and
like I said their wives are just like
just think they're being ridiculous and
they're like look why don't we just all
go over there we'll meet this family
you'll see that that's totally fine
they're totally normal there's nothing
weird going on so they force all of them
to go over there and meet these people
and it's three of them the klopek sand
it's just like the hans who's like the
redheaded one and then there's one
that's played by Henry Gibson he's like
a doctor he's very like soft-spoken and
stuff and then there's another one
that's just kind of this grumpy crabby
old man and they go in the house and
they're just as weird as everybody
thinks they are like they're acting
really weird and sketchy and they make
them they don't have any snacks for them
they just make them eat out of it like
this tin of sardines and [ __ ] like that
and it's just like super weird so
there's that whole thing going on and I
didn't mention to that also you know
during all of this crazy [ __ ]
there is also [ __ ] Corey Feldman is
also in this movie and he is like he's
like a teenager but he lives next door
to Bruce darns character and he's
supposed to be painting his house but
he's just like all jazz because he's
like oh you guys are like you know he's
he's like watching them like what
they're doing like trying to find out of
us like it's really exciting for him so
he starts inviting all his friends over
like just because all this shit's gonna
happen
you know they're ordering pizza they're
like sitting out drinking beers smoking
weed like on their porch like watching
all this [ __ ] unfolding so as this whole
thing goes on you kind of you kind of
get to a thing where you think that it's
all going to end up that the khlo pecks
are just weird or there's other because
you know they think that he that they
killed this old man Walter and then late
in the movie you know what after they've
already broken into the house they find
a thing in the basement that they think
is a crematorium they start like digging
in there like looking for bones they hit
the gas line they blow the [ __ ] house
up and then they see that Walter comes
home and it turned out that Walter had
like a heart attack or had some kind of
health issue and like his family took
him to the hospital and they forgot you
know and his dog was running around and
stuff like that so Walter is alive so
then all of them think oh well we [ __ ]
up we're stupid we just blew their whole
entire [ __ ] house up and they didn't
do anything but plot twist at the very
very end and even like after like Tom
Hanks gives this big [ __ ] speech to
his friend played by Rick Duke a man
who's like you know we're the ones that
have been creeping around in their yard
and we're the ones that broke into their
house we blew it up we did all this
other kind of [ __ ]
there's no they'd never did anything to
us and it's like you know we always
talked about all these people in
suburbia it's like they're secretly
psychos and stuff that's he's like
that's us he's like we're the ones that
we're doing all this [ __ ] so and you
think that that's like what the message
of the movie is that it's like you know
you know they shouldn't have just judged
them because they were weirdos or
whatever but then at the very end you
know Tom Hanks says you know the house
is blown up and he gets hurt so he has
to go to the thing and then the doctor
klopek who's played by Henry Gibson like
gets in the ambulance with him and says
oh well I know you probably found that
skull that I had in the crematorium so
I'm gonna have to kill you now and then
it's and then he like flips out and he's
like running out of the thing and then
it turns out that the trunk of their car
is just full of skeletal remains so it
turned out that the crazy dudes that
were stalking this poor family were
right all along not only have these the
khlo pecks like killed a whole bunch of
people they also killed the people who
used to live in the house
because it was a thing earlier about how
they didn't know like where the where
the people that lived in that house went
to and it turned out that the clove X
had killed them like to take the house
over and had killed other people too so
so in a way it's like I liked that it
kind of subvert of the message of you
know cuz like I said you think the whole
message of the movie is like you know it
was all a big misunderstanding it's like
they were just weirdos and you
suburbanite sore like so square and you
just thought you're just picking on them
because they're different from you but
it turned out that they were correct
that these people that were different
from them were indeed mass murderers and
they were actually right not not
necessarily blow their house up but you
know they were actually right that you
know they were up to something what
you're just come out of 1989 okay I
thought was earlier than that I did too
actually and it was like really funny
when you know when shudder put it up
there and I was like really excited I
was like oh I wanted to do this movie
because I haven't seen it in such a long
time and then I could have sworn that it
came out I thought it came out the same
year as dragnet which came out in 1987
good all about that one yeah that had
Tom Hanks in it to you and Dan Aykroyd
that was actually pretty funny although
I haven't seen that in a really long
time either so it might not have held up
but I think this one really does you
know like I said even though I thought
it was earlier so I was like what is a
movie of its time it is yeah from it's
definitely from a culture that's not
really around anymore when you think
about it there isn't it there is some of
that suburban stubble you know we live
in the modern-day equivalent of that
yeah now is that people aren't really
like that anymore a different
generational changes yeah but yeah look
at when I watched it you know III didn't
see it back then when I watched I looked
at it now to me it was it was kind of
like a period piece I like yeah but it
didn't really to me didn't really push
push the same buttons that have pushed
in you because I didn't see it as a kid
so I didn't really yeah have a long
history of no I mean I wasn't a kid when
I saw it I was well you seen something
like that that's well kids just yeah but
um you know that so another thing that I
like so even
no like I said probably gremlins is the
more famous Joe Dante I mean I know he's
directed like a [ __ ] ton of stuff and I
feel like this one kind of flies under
the radar but in a way I like this one
better because one it they're still like
zany [ __ ] that happens but it's not as
over-the-top zany as gremlins is it's
more believable because nothing really
supernatural happens or anything like
that it's basically just these weirdos
that live next to them that are killing
people you know and them trying to find
out about it like [ __ ] that's
unbelievable happens but nothing is like
paranormal or anything like that
watching it kind of reminded me of them
of Edward Scissorhands to a certain
interest yeah yeah it's kind of the same
didn't really had that same you know
stylistic thing that yeah what's his
name does what they did Tim Burton
timbered get to eat all Tim Burton
movies are Tim Burton II yeah yeah I
mean this one Tim really had that Tim
Burton enos to it it was more along the
lines of imagine if to me it kind of
felt like what would a comedy made by
Spielberg look like because any comedy
made by Steven Spielberg with Ellen with
horror elements it kind of had like a
Spielberg E and vibe but I think a lot
of people kind of emulated some of
Spielberg well yeah you know in that era
and it's kind of gonna come back to ya
and I think in a way to that I mean the
whole Spielberg aesthetic I think that
was something that I don't know if he
did it on purpose but I think Joe Dante
was definitely trying to not necessarily
subvert it but I actually kind of have
fun with it you know in the sense that
you know whereas something like
poltergeist was here's a nice
middle-class family nice middle-class
neighborhood or upper-middle class
whatever you want to call it and then
it's invaded by paranormal forces what
if you were invaded by your neighbors
like what if the same thing happened but
like they were up to something
yeah and Jenny told gave it pretty
accurate kind of play-by-play of what
happens in this movie and really it
doesn't do it justice because yeah you
have to see it happen the delivery the
way the way the movie delivered these
scenes is you know
pretty entertaining like I said that is
the best thing and it's another kind of
movie that has so many like great
quotable lines like so many like little
just great little scenes and I feel like
it doesn't get it doesn't have like the
same pop-culture cachet it's like maybe
some other movies from the 80s like that
have like kind of catchphrases or things
that people remember and that's kind of
a shame because I really think
particularly Tom Hanks and brick do
common and this are really really good I
think they play off each other really
well cuz Rick do come in like I said
he's kind of like a big dumb you know
jokester kind of thing and then Tom
Hanks is just like a regular guy but
also kind of dorky and he does funny
[ __ ] like without it really without
really trying to be funny but I mean
there's just such great little I mean
there's a scene at the beginning where
Rick Duke a man comes over to the
Petersons house and like you know Tom
Hanks and the family are sitting around
eating breakfast and you know Rick
Dickerman is just like talking about the
neighbors and how we're there and he's
just going around their kitchen just
eating [ __ ] out of their fridge and like
no one is saying anything it's just like
this great little there's just great
little moments like that like through
the whole thing kind of just took me
back to a pre-internet suburban culture
yeah it definitely it definitely does it
was a simple yeah it definitely
definitely does have that vibe to it and
I really and I kind of like here the
mall music playing in the band yeah I
was actually I was watching a video
earlier that was like kind of a review
of the burbs and the guy that made the
video was reframing the movie as as
Ricky who is Corey Feldman's character
as he was the one that it was almost
like a meta movie like Ricky was the one
that was like engineering all of it like
as an entertaining like as entertainment
for his party that he was having and
like he the argument that he made for it
was actually pretty good because Ricky's
character is kind of like I'm not gonna
say he's like the audience surrogate but
he's kind of like a little bit outside
of it and he's just kind of like
watching what's going on he just thinks
everything that's going on is holy
Arius and awesome and he just wants like
all his friends to see it and so they're
just like sitting on the porch with the
pizza or whatever and you know he kind
of gets involved with it and stuff like
that but it's interesting like how his
character kind of interacts with all of
it like almost like he's watching all of
it from afar but he's out it's almost
kind of like he's controlling it as well
but this guy had that kind of approach
to the movie and I thought that was kind
of interesting and I was like yeah I
guess I guess that is what takes you
back John when you take your mom's car
go pick up your friends you go down to
Blockbuster video arcade play some
[ __ ] what's Ikari warriors or you
know rest an or you know some [ __ ] like
that for a few hours and then you go
back and watch movies yes from that er
yeah I mean that's exactly it's got that
vibe I could I could see the I could see
that interior design of Blockbuster
Video as I watch and like I said and and
you mentioned this before it's like yeah
you know I can give like a synopsis of
the plot and stuff like that it's like
Oh creepy but you really have to see it
because so much of the comedy in it and
a lot of it is physical comedy too
particularly from Tom Hanks it's just
like his facial expressions like the way
he moves his arms as almost like a
vaudevillian yeah it's it's just like
it's just like really really funny like
one of my favorite scenes like I said
after this [ __ ] you know speech he
gives at the end before they realized
that the khlo pecks are actually
murderers when he's giving this speech
to Ric do come by me the [ __ ] houses
are on fire the cops are there it's like
everyone's like standing out it's the
middle of the night it's this big
disaster area and he's like yelling at
Ric Dickerman like how they're the crazy
ones and we should leave these people
alone they didn't do anything to us and
then there's like this big long pause
and then Ric dikmen's like so what you
want me to like move or something and
then Tom Hanks just like pauses and then
he just runs that starts like wailing
[ __ ] and it's just like his timing on
that is just like impeccable and
everything about it like you know when
one of the klopek Slyke gives him the
[ __ ] sardine and his wife's like yeah
eat it you know just to be polite or
whatever and then he's like put in his
mouth and he's like you could tell it's
like totally disgusting this is a big
long shot of him just like trying to
swallow me it's just like just great
little [ __ ] like that
understand Peabody does uh yeah I can't
either it's like I don't know and I love
fish
I even like like fishy I even I even
like fishy tasting fish but I can't I
keep those oysters out of the cab back
he knows I can't eat this fish it's just
too oily there's so much cool [ __ ] yeah
and they don't smell that good either
but yeah so that's so like I said
shudder just added this actually they
added a whole bunch of joe dante movies
they added gremlins 1 gremlins to the
new batch so and like I said the burbs
I'm gonna go out on a limb and say I
actually like this a little bit better
than the first gremlins just because
it's it's more of a black comedy you
know I guess you could say gremlins is a
black comedy too but it's it's more of
just a zany comedy comedy that just has
some horror movie elements to it it's
not all that scary this one's not really
scary either but like I said it's more
grounded in reality and it just has more
of a black like comedic kind of tone and
I think like the ensemble cast is really
the best part of it it's like everybody
is good in this and just the way they
interact with each other it's just like
super super it's just a good late
eighties movie there's you know yeah it
held up for a movie of its time
well yeah and like any movie you have to
see it you know within the cultural
context yeah um and maybe I always kind
of wonder about that because I'm like
maybe we like these but although you
know people that didn't live through the
80s seem to still like movies from the
80s but it probably has like more of a
richness more of a resin oh that's
because we lived through yeah I talked
to I talked to some of our subscribers
online every now and then and I'll
recommend some of the older movies to
like some young people like you know
like Sophie yeah and I heard her
boyfriend watch it and I don't think
they quite had the same impact for them
because they weren't there at the time
yeah they're like these are kind of old
movies you know that's you know I mean
like I don't know and yeah it's Jonah
showing somebody who's 21 years old
showing them total recall the original
eternal Swartz negative yeah it's not
the same as showing it to a 50 year old
man who was there although I was alive
when that Total Recall came out and I
still think it's kind of cheesy yes man
it was cheesy then yeah loved it you
know I mean it didn't have to look
realistic it was a kind of a comic book
movie yeah and it was a bunch of fantasy
science fiction fantasy and it was a
mind-bending type stuff we did a show on
it yeah did show on it then we did yeah
and yeah it wasn't was it meant to be
taken totally seriously just to make you
think you know where we were forgiving
yeah back then yeah yeah might have been
yeah because movie budgets weren't we're
nowhere near as big as they are now yeah
sure I mean they're making 500 million
dollar budget movies and [ __ ] although I
have to tell you that like sometimes we
see like these really big budget movies
like with a lot of CGI and it still
looks fake yeah still doesn't look that
good
something cyanide take a rubber monster
a week at least it's there some of those
iconic movies like you know the arnold
schwarzenegger was pumping out we're
front was wasn't even at all should you
cook aurelio cook cook Aurelio what are
you talking about that old 80 studio
Corelli oh I think it was as the symbol
was all the Seas in the inside Thanon no
not can not that bad bad I don't
remember it was Kirill EO was name of it
and you know Dave these movies were only
a couple million to make yeah and
they're still around yeah you know I'm
well even nowadays I'm kind of like I
don't know maybe it's cuz we grew up in
the 70s and 80s it's if something is
entertaining I don't care how shitty it
looks and you know me I'll watch pretty
much anything pretty much anything we
were talking about this in the car the
other day cuz we were talking about our
you know our matinee show where we go
see movies and stuff and I was just kind
of like you know I I don't have a
problem going to see pretty much
anything the only thing I can't really
stomach is like really like locky like
that like that drama movies that we
watch like that was painful that was
like painful to sit through Christian
adjacent movies yeah like all those like
really just super earnest like almost
like a religious flick yeah like I can't
the that's pretty much the only thing I
can't really sit through I will sit
through pretty much anything else you
know don't test me on that but I'm just
saying there's I mean obviously there's
certain genres that I like better than
others but I'm pretty
open to like whatever because there have
been movies in genres I don't really
care for that I thought were awesome you
know what I mean
I'm not a huge fan of westerns but
there's a lot of westerns that I think
are really awesome you know what I mean
so it's that kind of thing so I don't
know if it's just like an age thing or
anything like that but if you like 80s
movies and you particularly like you
know if you like gremlins or you know
have the howling even which the howling
was more of a horror movie but I guess
it had some comedic elements to Joe
Dante always kind of put some funny [ __ ]
in his movies this is I would call this
a pretty much straight up it's a comedy
with a large dollop of horror in it you
know a black comedy I would call it with
some horror elements so if you haven't
seen it like I said it's tends to fly
under the radar because everyone talks
about grandma wants gremlins but I feel
like more people should probably see
this one because it's really funny it
has like a really lot of funny quotable
lines a lot of physical humor that um
that you know I can't do it because it's
yeah yeah you have to see it and shudder
just added it the other day so if you
have shudder then you can check it out
and everybody should so go check it out
right now because we said so yeah
and that'll do it for our latest movie
retrospective remember if you liked the
show like share subscribe on all your
social media and if you'd like to
financially support ship you can go to
our patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
podcast wordpress comm and there's a
button in the sidebar to a PayPal
account if you'd like TiVo one donation
one time donation it would be much
appreciated remember that our regular
episodes come out every Tuesday these
movie retrospectives just like this one
come out every Friday and 13 o'clock
matinee three new movies in theatres
come out every Sunday so check them out
we will see you next time bye